Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show I'm your
host Deffinition aka your friendly neighbourhood
spoiler-man and I have watched Avengers: Endgame
an INSANE Amount of times.
Whether it's the way it closes out the saga
or just the nice little callbacks in the movie,
something keeps calling me back.
I'm currently in the middle of making a big
watching order video for all the Marvel properties
and over the last eight months I've watched
everything that falls under the umbrella.
Whether it's Agent Carter, Agents Of Shield,
Cloak and Dagger, Daredevil or the movies
themselves, chances are, you name it, I've
watched it.
With all this info stuffed in my head I've
noticed some crazy details in Avengers: Endgame
and throughout this video I'm gonna be breaking
down some of the best things that most people
have missed.
There will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't seen Avengers: Endgame and do'...who
am I kidding, you've seen the movie.
Make sure you subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day now let's get into
our breakdown of Insane Details you missed
in Avengers: Endgame.
Infinity War Details
Ok so one of the best things about Infinity
War and Endgame as a whole is that the latter
pays off so many minor things in former that
the Russo Brother's should be applauded for
their sheer amount of attention to detail.
Both movies were filmed back to back but even
so there are still some tiny little self-referential
things that show not only character detail
but also add to the world building.
When talking to Doctor Strange, Tony Stark
and Wong, Bruce Banner is surprised to learn
that Ben and Jerry's have named an ice cream
flavour after him.
This gets a big followup in Endgame when we
can see Hulk eating it during the planning
stages of the time heist.
Also in Infinity War, Tony uses a nanotech
shield to cover himself from an attack by
Thanos.
This severely depletes his supply of the microscopic
machines and leads to him being almost killed
by the Mad Titan.
In order make sure this doesn't happen again,
in Endgame, Stark instead uses an Energy shield
as protection which won't put a drain on his
armour.
Clearly he has learned from his mistakes and
he's not the only one either.
Throughout Infinity War after Thanos manages
to get his hands on two Infinity Stones, he
removes his armour, believing he is now invincible.
However at the end of the movie the character
is almost killed by Thor and thus when he
makes his attack at the end of Endgame, the
younger version of the character realises
that it's probably sensible to keep his armour
on.
Everytime Thor attacks the villain in the
film he goes for the head.
This was of course set up in Avengers: Infinity
War when due to his need to gloat he went
for his chest rather than an instant killing
blow.
Because of this Thanos was able to wipe out
half of all life within the Galaxy and retreat
to the garden.
In Endgame he's here to kill him properly
this time and from their first meeting, all
the way until the final battle, everytime
Thor clashes with the character he aims directly
for his head.
During this fight, we watch the awesome moment
in which Captain America lifts Mjlnoir and
gains the power of Thor.
As Thanos cannot lift the item he instead
grabs Cap's wrists rather than the hammer
itself.
Cap's armour has scales on it and you can
actually see these under the upper layer of
his outfit in Infinity War.
These scales first made an appearance in Black
Panther and could show that after dropping
of Bucky in Wakanda, Shuri gave him some upgrades.
Earlier in the film The Hulkbuster grabs Thanos
and you can see that the left arm on the armor
is unpainted.
This is because it was detached during the
final battle in the prior movie.
Age Of Ultron
Thanos also breaks Cap's shield similar to
the way that it was destroyed in Tony Stark's
vision all the way back in Age Of Ultron.
Sacrifices
Infinity War was all about making sacrifices
in order to win.
Doctor Strange saved Tony in exchange for
handing over the time stone and there were
several more examples of this in the film.
I know this was part of his grand plan but
it still shows they put the few before the
many.
Cap famously said that they don't trade lives
when Vision offered his life up in order to
destroy the mind stone and they wouldn't make
the hard play.
Thus Thanos was able to collect all of the
Infinity Stones and win.
This is because he was willing to sacrifice
Gamora.
However, The Avengers win in Endgame because
they do make sacrifices including the death
of Black Widow and of course Tony Stark.
Thematically it's amazing and really pays
off what was set up in the prior film.
However, there are hints in Infinity War that
Gamora wasn't the first person to be sacrificed
for the Soul Stone.
As she lays there dead at the bottom of the
ravine we can see a pool of blood beside her.
Could this be Natasha's from 2014?
Well we do know that she did trade her life
and then Cap returned the Soul Stone so therefore
this moment would be permanent and it wouldn't
cause a branched timeline.
The blood isn't there when Natasha dies and
it would still remain after she perished.
Could it be that the Russo brothers were foreshadowing
Natashas death in Endgame during this moment
in the preceding film?
I think so.
When Natasha tells Steve that she has to work
on fixing everything the soundtrack is also
a variation on the Soul Stone sacrifice music
which foreshadows her death later.
Returning The Stones
When Steve sets out on his mission to return
the stones he says to Bucky.
“Don’t do anything stupid until I get
back."
Bucky replies
“How can I?
You’re taking all the stupid with you,”
This is actually a callback to Captain America:
The First Avenger in which the conversation
was reversed with Steve delivering the opposite
dialogue to Bucky before he went off to fight
in World War 2.
Before leaving on his mission, Cap looks in
the direction of where his old version would
later be sat and says 'I'll be back.'
At the end of the film Steve and Peggy finally
get that dance and it's the same song from
when Steve found fury in his apartment in
the winter soldier.
The song is called 'It's been a long long
time' which is of course a reference to the
journey that Steve has been on to finally
get his long lost love.
When taking the Pym Particles from Hank, he
takes four in total.
This is two for him and Stark to return to
the present and one for him to go to the past
and another to eventually return to the present.
After returning from the past on his own little
journey Hawkeye seems pretty beat.
Scott grabs some orange slices which is a
call back to Civil War in which he asked if
anyone had any to help ease his pain.
Natasha makes a Peanut Butter Jelly sandwich
which Scott then shows up and eats.
She cuts it diagonally which is a call back
to Nick Fury telling Carol that he can't eat
toast that's been cut diagonally.
Could she be in the habit of doing this to
stop Nick from stealing her lunch at work?
We'd like to think so.
Thor Ragnarok
That's not the only neat little easter egg
that ties into other movies in the MCU.
In Thor Ragnarok before Odin Dies he says
to Thor and his brother 'remember this place,
home.'
This scene takes place in Norway and is actually
the location that New Asgard would come to
be in Endgame.
But it's not the only time the area makes
a big appearance.
Tonsberg has been a crucial location in the
MCU from the beginning.
This is the location where the Asgardians
fought centuries ago, it's also where the
tesseract was hidden and then taken by Red
Skull and it is of course where Odin dies
and New Asgard comes to be.
During Ragnarok a line is also set up and
paid off in Endgame.
Loki tells Thor that he cannot see into the
future as he's not a witch.
In Endgame Frigga can tell that Thor is from
the future because as she says she was 'raised
by Witches.'
This implies that Witches can tell the future
in the MCU and I love the way it references
this line from the third Thor film.
Tony And His Dad
It's not the only touching exchange between
parent and child son that has major callbacks
to the MCU either and in Endgame when Howard
asks Tony about his father, Stark Junior says
'He did his best.'
This is a nod to the BARF demonstration in
Civil War in which Tony shows that he wishes
he told his father 'I love you dad, and I
know you did the best you could'.
I'm not crying.
You're crying!
During this scene Jarvis from Agent Carter
pops up too.
I know you've probably heard that one a hundred
times I just wanted to add it in.
Avengers
There's tonnes of call back too and loads
of nice little easter eggs in the scene in
which Tony and Scott go to Stark Tower in
2012.
Tony's armor retracts from the feet first
to silence his landing and make it so they
aren't heard entering the room.
Thor says that they're going for lunch which
is a reference to the Schwarma scene from
the post credits scene of the film.
Tony also flicks Ant-Man with insane accuracy
because he'd been practicing playing Paper
Football with Nebula for weeks.
When exiting the building, Tony replays a
similar move to which he did in the first
Avengers movie, however his suit quickly engages
over him instead of when he almost hits the
pavement which shows how far his technology
has come since 2012.
The Quantum Suits
Speaking of technology the Quantum suits themselves
also show the melding of a lot of the tech
in the MCU.
They use Pym tech in order to shrink, the
Nano Tech is from Iron-Man and Wakanda's nano
machines and the visor is from the Guardians
and Ratchet...sorry I mean Rocket.
Speaking of Ratchet, Tony calls him this in
the film and it's a reference to the furry
Sony character who is also great with machines.
Community Cast
The Russos love casting people from their
previous work and Anthony Russo's daughter
plays Hawkeyes in the film.
This is who he is seen training in the beginning
and you may notice sounds of birds and wildlife
in the background.
After the snap is carried out these disappear
showing that a lot of animals were also killed
when Thanos carried out the devastating move.
The child we see in Captain America: The Winter
Soldier also returns to take a picture with
Smart Hulk at the diner scene.
Two community actors also pop up including
Yvette Nicole Brown who gets in a lift with
Steve and Tony and also Ken Jeong who is a
guard at the lock-up.
Jeong is reading a book called Terminal Breach
which is about a President who decides to
destroy countless nuclear weapons at the cost
of millions of lives.
This of course has ties to Thanos' plan in
which he killed trillions in order to save
the Galaxy.
The lockup Ant-Man is in is 616 which is a
reference to the main Marvel universe which
also carries this designation.
Final Battle
Spider-Man told Tony in Civil War that he'd
never get a chance to play football due to
his powers but we see him get the opportunity
in the final battle in which the character
literally runs the guantlet.
In Spider-man: Homecoming there's a hilarious
scene in which Peter thought Tony was going
for a hug.
Tony says "We're not there yet".
but in "Endgame" Tony and Peter hug which
shows how far their friendship
has come.
You can also see Peter's traditional Spider-man
costume under the suit when it's damaged.
This is because he had it on under the Iron-Spider
Armour all the way back in Infinity War.
As he died on Titan and then came straight
to the final battle after being ressurected
he wouldn't have had time to change.
The final battle has tonnes of tiny little
things in it that you may miss if you're not
playing close attention.
When War Machine is stuck in Avengers HQ he
gets out the suit by saying 'canopy, canopy,
canopy' which is code for 'eject, eject, eject'
in the air force.
A pilot says this to their backseater so they
can leave first.
You can also see Iron Patriot Mark 2 Armor
in the background of this scene which makes
an appearance later on.
When fighting Thanos Cap throws the shield
and then the hammer at the shield which knocks
Thanos off balance and is a callback to when
the two struck one another in Avengers.
The Wasp exists a tiny small portal and we
also see Spider-man swinging on Ant-Man in
order to move forward.
The end of the film culminates with Tony carrying
out the snap and killing Thanos and his forces.
Not only can you hear Tony's Nano machines
taking the stones of Thanos' gauntlet and
putting them into his suit but there are also
a couple of neat little callbacks to the prior
film.
the first time we hear Thanos talk in Infinity
War he says he knows what it's like to lose
and how it turns the legs to jelly.
When dying, the first thing he does is sit
down.
Why this scene is also perfect is because
the camera movement mimics his victory at
the end of Avengers Infinity War.
It pans across exactly the same way and show
the victory and defeat in a similar light.
Tony's funeral
At Tony's funeral everyone rocks back and
forth except for Mantis who sways in a rocking
motion.
This was put in place because it's typical
of Mantids to sway when stood still.
Morgan tells Happy that she wants some cheeseburgers
and this is a reference to the first Iron-Man
in which Tony made Happy get him some cheeseburgers
after returning home from being held hostage.
The credits ends with the clanging noise of
Iron-Man building his suit in the first film
and this brings everything full circle.
All 22 films which is also paid lip service
to by Stark in the beginning of Endgame who
says they've been adrift for 21 days...no
22.
Your thoughts
And that's our entire list, I had a blast
making this video and I hope you had fun watching
it.
Obviously I’d love you hear your thoughts
on the tid bits so comment below and let me
know.
Make sure you subscribe to the channel for
videos like this everyday and if you want
something else to watch then make sure you
check out our breakdown of everytime that
Pennywise was hidden in the background of
a scene in It Chapter 1 and 2 which will be
linked at the end.
Every month on the 15th we give away free
blu rays and all you have to do to be in with
a chance of winning Doctor Sleep is leave
a like and subscribe with notifications on.
If you wanna support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider clicking
the join button.
You can also come chat to us on our discord
linked below or at deffinitionYT on Twitter.